منها طاي موفد العربيه عبد القادر خربوش
عبد القادر اهلا وسهلا بك اخر اخبار
الهزات الارتداديه بدايه وكيف تسير عمليه
اعاده بناء ما تهدم
هنا حيث اقف لا حديث عن اعاده البناء طالب
الحديث كله الان والجهود كلها مركزه على
فتح الطرقات التي ما تزال بعضها مغلقه
بفعل الضمار الهائل
فك المسالك على الاقل لتتمكن هذه الشاحنات
من اخراج ما يمكنها اخراجه من اطنان
الركام التي قدرها وزير الداخليه قبل قليل
وزير الداخليه تركي في تصريح رسمي قال بان
انطاكيا حيث اقف وهاتاي لوحدها ينتظر ان
يتم اخراج منها 15 مليون طن تخيل معي طالب
هذا الرقم وهذا الوزن الهائل ما يوحي بان
المدينه كلها تحولت الى ركام وهذا ما
لاحظناه ونلاحظه خلال
تجوالنا اما عن اعمال البناء فتتركز في
مناطق اخرى حيث تم الاعلان اليوم على شروع
السلطات في بناء 20 مدينه منازل مسبقه
الجهات في
ولايه اديمان لواء المرتقب ان تاوي هذه
المدينه سبعين الف شخص متضرر من هذه
الزلازل ايضا فيما يتعلق بالهزات
الارتداديه المستمره كانت اقواها واخرها
التي ضربت ولايه نجده وتم الاعلان عنها
رسميا من قبل مدير منظمه واداره الكوارث
والطوارئ التركيه بانها تعتبر زلزال مستقل
لحاله هذا فيما يتعلق بهزات الارتداديه
الاعمال وعمليه التحقيق في اسباب هذه
الزلازل او على الاقل في اسباب هذا العدد
الكبير من الوفيات والمباني التي تحطمت
هناك توقيفات اليوم ايضا طالت شخصيات
ورؤساء بلديات اخرهم كان تابعه للحزب
الحاكم اي حزب العداله والتنميه وهو رئيس
بلديه في ولايه غازي عنتاب وهذا كان سجالا
سياسيا حدث قبل ايام بين المعارضه والحزب
الحاكم والائتلاف الحاكم طيب
ساكتفي بهذا القدر منها طائر موفد العربيه
عبد القادر خربوش شكرا جزيلا لك عبد
القادر على كل هذه المتابعه